Speaker 1: Let's talk about political fundraising.
We've been looking at polling, but we have
not been looking at fundraising.
The second quarter just ended.
The second quarter is April, May and June.
And we have some very interesting new fundraising
data.
I do not yet have Joe Biden's fundraising
data for the second quarter.
When I have it, I will tell you what it is.
But Donald Trump's fundraising has exploded
significantly in Q2, assuming, of course,
that the Trump campaign is being honest in
their reporting.
Trump pulled in per politico more than $35
million in the second quarter.
That is nearly double what Trump raised in
Q1 and suggests.
Politico writes that the indictments are helping
with fundraising, and the article goes into
detail in Q1.
Trump raised just under $19 million in Q2.
Trump raised more than $35 million.
Important to note, the joint fundraising committee
is split between Trump's official campaign
and his leadership PAC, Save America.
At least in theory, the Save America PAC is
meant to raise money for people that Trump
endorses or supports.
The official did not break down how much of
that 35 million went to Trump versus the PAC.
But the most recent fundraising solicitations
direct 90% of each donation to Trump's campaign
and 10% to the Save America PAC.
The PAC, by the way, also lately is focusing
spending on non-campaign activity, like paying
for Trump's legal bills.
So there are a few different things to talk
about here.
First and foremost, the average donation was
$34 in $0.20.
We have people.
Who can only afford to give about 30 bucks
paying for a billionaire's legal fees.
A billionaire who has a private jet, they
are sending money to a guy with a private
plane for his legal fees.
Because of all of the crimes he allegedly
committed and all they can really do, it's
30 bucks because statistically, they can't
meet an unexpected $400 expense that they
might be presented with.
That's insane.
That is insane.
And grift after grift.
You know, I hate to do this.
Sort of, like, caveat emptor.
A fool and their money are soon parted.
We can't have a nanny state protecting these
people.
Like, I don't want to go in that direction.
But after the grift of 2016, where Trump raised
money, money, money, despite saying, I don't
really need any money, I'm rich enough to
run on my own with all of these promises that
he didn't meet.
And then he ran again in 2020 saying, I'm
making the same promises all over again, even
though I didn't meet them in the first campaign.
This time I will.
And people donate and then Trump loses.
And then there's this Hey, now I need your
money in order to overturn elections and do
forensic audits where we're going to look
ballot by ballot for bamboo fibers or barbecue
sauce or whatever the case they were looking
for and also for filing lawsuits.
And then half of that 70% of that went to
paying Trump's campaign bills.
GRift after grift after grift.
And now he's doing it again.
And they're still donating money for legal
fees.
At this point, I don't think there's anyone
who can protect these people, and probably
we shouldn't even continue trying.
I want to hear from you on that question.
Should these folks who continue to donate
money to the obvious grift, should we even
care at this point or at some point?
Is it a matter of personal responsibility
like Republicans love to say and they need
to be parted with their money if they are
going to fall for it again?
Let me know what you think.
We are going to keep an eye on the Biden fundraising
numbers.
Also, as far as fundraising.
This is a very interesting report from Axios
from yesterday called Democrats Amass Early
War Chest for Brutal 2024 Senate Map.
The 2024 Senate map is not a great map for
Democrats.
Remember that with 100 senators in the Senate
every two years, a third of them are up for
reelection.
The terms are six years long.
But these are sort of overlapping classes
in the Senate.
The third of the Senate that happens to be
up for reelection in 2024 is not particularly
good for Democrats.
What is very interesting is that a number
of a number of prominent Democrats are doing
really well in terms of fundraising.
Senator Bob Casey in Pennsylvania has raised
more than $4 million.
That's his best fundraising quarter ever.
Senator Tammy Baldwin from Wisconsin, first
openly LGBT woman in the Senate, raised over
$3 million.
That is also a record high.
Adam Schiff broke the record for second quarter
Senate fundraising.
Remember, he's a member of Congress, but he's
running for Dianne Feinstein seat, which he
will be vacating.
These are stunning, stunning, stunning numbers.
But there are many Republicans who are doing
well as well.
In Nevada, retired U.S. Army Captain Sam Brown
is likely to launch a Senate campaign against
the Democrat there.
And that potentially is going to do well in
terms of fundraising.
There are Republicans who have the potential
with major Republican Senate campaign support
to also do well.
But the encouraging sign here is it does it
right now.
If we want a proxy to enthusiasm for 2024,
we would look at fundraising.
I don't have the Biden Q two numbers, but
I do have some Senate Q2 numbers and they
look very good, particularly considering that
it's July of the year before the election.
Hope is not lost and the Senate could end
up being okay in 2024.
That's where we'll leave it.
We'll take a quick break after this.
I am going to talk about threads, the new
Twitter competitor.
We're going to talk about so many different
things.
Glad you're with us today.
I want to welcome all of our new podcast listeners.
The reason I mention that specifically is
that we just got the June numbers and they
are super strong.
Even Trump's pollster MacLachlan would have
to admit that these are very, very good numbers.
825,000 podcast downloads in June.
That's the best month we've ever had in the
history of the show.
And we're pushing towards a million a month
as far as podcast downloads.
And I want to welcome everybody who has found
us through the audio podcast.
I also want to remind you we are primarily
a funded by the audience program.
You can get a membership at join Packman dot
com.
I won't bore you with the details.
You can read about them on our web site, but
we do depend on you to do what we do and you
can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code indicted again
all one word no space for a sizable discount.
And we do an extra show every day for our
members.
So if you like this show, my sense is you'll
like the bonus show.
Alex Jones doesn't like it.
Howard Stern likes it but won't pay for it.
But it is what it is.
Join Pacman dot com is the place to sign up.